Serious injuries and deaths from
accidents in cars have
more than halved over
the last 20 years.
It's not because we've got any
better at driving, it's
because we've got better
at safety engineering.
Things like seat belts
and air bags.
Whilst we've got really quite
good at protecting heads in
accidents, we're getting to a
stage where protection for
other parts of the body are
starting to lag behind.
In fact, the second most likely
cause of sudden death
in a car accident is something
called an aortic rupture.
The aorta is the largest blood
vessel in your body.
It comes straight out of your
heart and carries oxygenated
blood up to your brain
and around to the
rest of your body.
It sits inside the chest cavity,
in the middle there,
with the aorta arching out of
the heart and back and down,
right in front of the
spinal column.
If you're driving along a road
like this, at 60 miles an hour
like I am, and the car crashes,
it comes to a very
sudden stop.
And everything in the car has
to come to very sudden stop.
So if you're wearing a seat
belt, that has to put a very
large force on your chest to
stop your chest moving.
Now, the internal organs, your
heart, your lungs, are still
moving forward.
And they've got to be stopped.
My heart sitting in my chest,
weighing about 300 grams.
When you have a crash, the
accelerations are enormous,
probably of the order
of about 70G.
What that means is the forces
your heart experiences are 70
times normal.
So something more like the
weight of 21 kilograms.
That can do some damage.
But there's something really odd
about aortic ruptures that
might give us a clue as
to why they happen
in the first place.
Whether you're in a car
accident, on a motorcycle, or
even falling out of a high
building, the aorta ruptures
in the same place.
If you do have an aortic
rupture, with the heart
beating and pumping blood out
at that sort of rate, it's
enough to empty your
entire blood volume
out in about a minute.
And that's the reason why most
aortic ruptures are fatal.
The place it ruptures is just a
bit where the arch turns the
corner to a place called
the isthmus, there.
And this is really a
very interesting
place for that to happen.
It suggests a hypothesis that
the reason it bursts there is
because there's a weak
point there.
That corresponds to a feature
of the circulatory system in
foetuses, where there are a
couple of short circuits
between the circulation
to the lungs and the
circulation to the body.
Foetuses don't need to use their
lungs, because they get
the oxygen from the placenta.
So these short circuits divert
the blood back to the body.
One of them is a short tube that
joins the aorta on to the
artery that comes out of the
heart to the lungs, closes up
at the moment of birth, but
leaves a small scar, just at
the point where we find
aortic ruptures occur.
That's why we have the
hypothesis that the weak point
in the aorta is located there.
Because the people who die from
aortic ruptures tend to
be young and healthy, we usually
use young and healthy
aortas from the butcher.
But that's a bit messy
for today.
We'll just use a balloon.
To test whether the aorta
ruptures at a weak point, we
took samples of aorta from that
place, and from other
places, to see if it
really was weaker.
Now to simulate accident
conditions, we have to do that
at high strain rates.
And that's where the experiment
starts to get fun.
This is how we test a section of
aorta that's clamped across
a hole there.
We can pop it like a bubble with
compressed air that we
let in with this valve.
And we can measure the pressure
and watch how it
deforms, so we can quantify
its mechanical properties.
So that's all that's left
of my bit of balloon.
When we did the experiment with
the aortas, we found that
the rupture pressure at the
point where we thought the
weak point was was just the same
as the rupture pressure
higher or lower down
the aorta.
So we can't confirm
that hypothesis.
Back to the drawing board.
Best you can do at the moment
is just to wear a seat belt.